okay we're in the deep end already
let's go to the mariana trench
what happens when you die
well if you're a physicalist
it's quite clear right your
consciousness
is entirely the product
of your brain or your embodied
brain i mean some of my colleagues will
emphasize
the cycle between sort of an inactive
point of view that it's not just the
brain it's the brain and the body in the
environment in that loop
that loop fine but
when you die that loop stops and
therefore your consciousness stops and
so
from that point of view it's it's the
prediction is quite clear there's
nothing that survives death
um from you that that i'm proposing here
space time itself is not fundamental
the brain does not cause anything
including our conscious experiences
instead
instead space time is like our headset
it's a virtual reality headset
but so consciousness
does not have to die
when the body dies but as i said
the self is not fundamental in the
theory that i'm developing
the self is just a data structure like
space time is a data structure
so from the point of view that i'm
working on right now
my death does not mean that
my consciousness disappears but myself
may
i don't know yet i mean that's going to
be something i want to work on in
this theory the self just being a data
structure maybe that data structure
dissolves
or maybe it's like
[Music]
what happens in metamorphosis
a caterpillar becoming a butterfly
right in some sense there's not much
recognizable
left of the caterpillar when the
butterfly emerges
there is a a continuity but
you know the butterfly has
only six legs the the caterpillar
had quite a few more the caterpillar
eats leaves
the butterfly can't eat leaves the
butterfly drinks nectar the caterpillar
never drank
nectar the butterfly has wings
caterpillar has no concept of wings
they're they're the same creature at
different stages but they're utterly
alien and and maybe the thing that
survives
death is as different from me as a
butterfly is from a caterpillar
um and it you know so i i just don't
know so
i'm still on that i'll be be very
interested to work on the mathematics
and see um but i'll give you an analogy
that may be that may be helpful here so
suppose you go to a virtual reality
arcade with some friends
to play say virtual volleyball you put
on your headset and bodysuit and you see
yourself emerge immersed in a beach
volleyball scene you see palm trees and
the net and sand and
your friend the avatars of your friends
cross the net and so you serve
the virtual volleyball and you guys play
for a while and then one of your friends
you know bob says excuse me i'm thirsty
i'm gonna go get a drink
and he takes off his headset in his body
suit to go get a drink
and his avatar collapses on the sand
well within that virtual reality
he's effectively dead but
of course bob isn't dead he just stepped
out of the interface
and so there's the sense in the theory
that i'm developing
that your body is just an avatar
the death of your body just like the
death of bob
in the virtual reality game is not the
death of bob bob just was not getting a
drink
so death may just be stepping out of the
interface but
even if consciousness survives the
consciousness that survives maybe is
different from the consciousness that
you now have as
you could imagine a butterfly being
different from a caterpillar
even more in the analogy of bob going to
get a drink there's a retainment of
memory
in your model i recall you
saying earlier in the conversation that
you don't have a
theory for memory or there is no memory
i could be wrong you might but
regardless does memory survive
death is it possible memories are data
structures as well
so those data structures
may or may not be preserved so that
would be another aspect of this whole
thing but
right now i have no reason to say up
front
that i would claim that they necessarily
are preserved so
i can't claim that that your current
notion of self would be preserved
or your current memories would be
preserved um and
the issue would then be could i build
models
of conscious agents in which
i first modeled what the death process
is as
in terms of stepping out of a particular
interface and can i find models
so but but notice what i'm saying here
now i'm actually trying to
model the death process with a
mathematical model
in terms of conscious agents and then
i'm asking a technical question
could certain data structures the self
data structure
memory my own personal episodic memory
data structures
be retained
in this other process that that is
leading to the extraction of
a conscious agent out of a particular
interface
that i don't know the answer to it but
for me it's a technical question and a
really interesting one
and and one that i don't think is
beyond our scope i think it's one that
we can address
we can try to find what i like about
what i like about your approach is it
reminds me of newtonian approximation
where you just guess at what one of the
roots are and you're
knowing you know full well that it's
likely to be wrong
but because of that guess you can get
closer and closer to the truth
that's how science works right you you
guess at the foundations
you guess what the right assumptions are
newton did a brilliant job i mean how do
you
probably one of the smartest men that
ever lived maybe the smartest
uh incredible brilliance and and
where he was wrong he
the new theories give i give
newton as an approximation like what
einstein gives newton as
as a limiting case as the speed of light
goes to infinity right newton
um is wrong but but he's deeply right
too he had his hands on something so
we would like to have assumptions in
this area of consciousness
as minimal as possible
but that then lead that turn all the
kinds of questions you're asking
into technical problems that we can in
principle solve and
all the questions you're asking so far
are ones i think that we can
pose as technical questions and try to
solve them